white nationalists march in washington
dc but only the media seem to care chris
cuomo is out at cnn and the biden
administration considers new coveted
restrictions despite the unthreatening
omicron data i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben sparrow show
the bench bureau show is sponsored by
expressivevpn you have a right to
privacy defend your rights at
expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first christmas quickly
approacheth and dudes if you are in the
market for a great christmas gift for a
lady in your life let me tell you about
the pearl sores okay because the pearl
source let me just tell you the best
quality pearl jewelry up to 70 off
retail prices i've gotten stuff from the
pearl source for my mom for my sisters
for my daughters at this point okay
everything at the pearl source is
beautiful they cut out the middleman by
eliminating those crazy jewelry store
markups and they sell directly to you
the customer at the pearl source you'll
find the largest selection of pearls
available anywhere and each jewelry
piece is custom made specifically for
you with global supply chain problems
and shipping carriers expecting major
delays as you get closer to the holidays
now would be the time to start shopping
for the holiday season do not wait the
pearl source offers fast and free
two-day shipping on every order with
zero contact delivery everything comes
beautifully packaged in an elegant jewel
box so it's ready to be given as a gift
if you're not sure you'll love the gift
no worries the pearl source comes with
that no hassle 60 day money-back
guarantee with free return shipping so
it is risk-free okay i can personally
attest to the quality of the products
also i know the owners and they are
wonderful wonderful people it's a great
family-owned business go shop right now
at thepearlsource.com
and get 20 off your entire order and
enter promo code bennett checkout again
20 off your entire order when you go to
thepearlsource.com
and use that promo code ben at checkout
go straight to the source the pearls the
prosource.com backslash ben enter promo
code ben at checkout for 20 off alrighty
so
over the weekend
bob dole passed away
he of course had run for the presidency
some three times he's the actual nominee
for the republican party in 1996 a
historic american figure who is a war
hero during world war ii is 98 years old
the president of the united states did
release a statement morning bob dole
said bob was an american statement like
few in our history a war hero among the
greatest of the greatest generations to
me he was a friend whom i could look to
for trusted guidance or a humorous line
at just the right moment to settle
frayed nerves i will miss my friend but
i'm grateful for the times we shared for
the friendship jill and i and our family
have built with liddy and the entire
dole family biden ordered that flags of
the white house and other public
buildings and facilities be flown at
half staff in honor of bob dole
according to a proclamation released by
the white house and of course he was a
historic american figure he had been
wounded during world war ii
and had suffered a series of health
ailments over the prior several decades
soul served 27 years as a u.s senator
from kansas he was senate majority
leader twice
he ran for president against bill
clinton in 1996 he was also gerald
ford's running mate in 1976 after nelson
rockefeller declined to stay on as vice
president
according to cnn early in his senate
career he was labeled a hatchet man by
his critics and drew national attention
for his vehement defense of richard
nixon throughout the watergate scandal
he considered nixon a friend and mentor
and he later eulogized nixon at his
funeral in 1994 as the most durable
public figure of our time
and he was a lawmaker and negotiator who
did work with democrats on issues like
social security reform the ada and
nutrition legislation many democrats
came out of the woodwork to praise him i
have to say part of that has to be the
fact that in this new world
democrats are willing to praise any
republican who is no longer in office
and is not donald trump those are the
those are the rules the way that it
works is you get a strange new respect
after you leave office as a republican
if you're in office as a republican
you're an evil white supremacist but if
you're out of office then you are a
wonderful person because you're a
hallmark of a better storied past in
american life when these evil
republicans of today weren't in power
and it is it is always striking to note
the complete disconnect in the language
that is used with regard to republicans
who were in office 30 years ago versus
republicans for an office today there
were some members of the media like
mehdi hassan who's awful over at msnbc
declaring that because bob dole
supported trump this was the most
notable thing about his life which is
kind of incredible considering again
that he enlisted at the age of 19 in the
us army following america's entry into
world war ii
he was set to fight in italy in 1945 but
he was seriously wounded while trying to
carry a fellow soldier to safety and
spent 39 grueling months in and out of
hospitals recuperating from his near
fatal injuries with left which left his
right arm permanently disabled his left
arm minimally functional he received the
purple heart twice two bronze stars with
an oak leaf cluster for his service in
world war ii
of course there there is
we we do have to know that there is a
difference in the class of of people who
run for office today versus the class
people who ran for office after world
war ii and george h.w bush was an actual
war hero bob dole is an actual war hero
uh today the kinds of people who we
elect to public office are instagram
heroes who mainly have large followings
online so we bid a fond farewell to bob
dole obviously now most of the news did
lead with bob dole at the top of the
news cnn did not however cnn led with
some other ancillary story about racism
in america's public schools or some such
meanwhile dana milbank has the piece of
the day over at the washington post and
this really is the theme of the biden
presidency right now is the media being
very upset that it has to be critical
with joe biden
so there are some members of the media
who've been attempting to cover joe
biden i think
with some level of fairness i don't
think all the media i think most of the
media have still been attempting to turn
a sal's person into a silk ear when it
comes to joe biden or to turn a zombie
president into george washington but
some members of me a few members of the
media have really done a better job at
covering joe biden than i thought they
would well this has driven dana milbank
over at the washington post to make the
following suggestion the media treats
joe biden as badly or worse than trump
here's proof
and now number one you just have to be
high to believe this you have to be out
of your mind to believe that the media
treat donald trump and joe biden in any
way similar to one another that's crazy
talk
okay maybe the reason that joe biden is
getting rough treatment from the press
right now is because he sucks and he's a
terrible president and maybe donald
trump receives horrible treatment from
the press literally from the day he
entered office and got no credit for any
of his accomplishments as presidents of
the united states those were all said to
be baked into the cake the only thing
that was unique about trump is what a
crazy person he was on twitter
the problem for the democrats and for
the press is that joe biden his policies
have been actually quite terrible and
have had a really negative market impact
on the united states remember up until
afghanistan all he got was glowing press
coverage then afghanistan happened and
even the media couldn't spin that one
away because it was so bad by the way a
million children are set to starve in
afghanistan over the course of the next
few months a million children thanks to
the genius decision making of the
president of the united states
we'll get to all of that in just one
second first let's talk about the
greatest underwear on the market i'm
talking of course about tommy john if
you are stuck on what to give your
friends and family this year wish them a
merry softness and happy new rear with
new comfy underwear loungeworm pajamas
from tommy john right now i can tell you
the underwear that grace this
magnificent took us those are tommy john
underwear they're the only underwear
that i own when your loved ones start
their day wearing tommy john they are
that much more comfortable so they can
do everything better tommy john lounge
wears luxuriously soft tri-blend and
micro modal fabrics mean four-way
stretch no lint no fuzz with over 17
million pairs sold giving the gift of
tommy john underwear and loungewear has
become a holiday tradition for families
all across the country 97 of women and
men love getting a gift from tommy john
that's why tommy john doesn't have
customers they have fanatics it's also
why i literally took all the other
underwear in my drawer and i threw them
out and i only wear tommy john now
returns or exchanges are free it's all
backed by tommy john's best pair you'll
ever wear or it's free guarantee get 20
off your first order right now at
tommyjohn.com
that's tommyjohn.com
for 20 off order now so your gifts
arrive before the holidays tommyjohn.com
ben see site for details alrighty so
again the reason that joe biden has
received disproportionately bad media
coverage in the past few months is
because of you know inflation and supply
chain crises and the fact that the man
is not perfectly sentient and also the
fact that again all of this started if
you go back just a few months this all
started like maybe four months ago when
joe biden decided to precipitously pull
out from afghanistan causing the fall of
that regime and the complete takeover
the taliban and that in turn resulted in
the subjugation of 19 million afghan
women and the murder of 13 american
service people because of joe biden
right that's when the media coverage
started to go real bad for him by the
way it is only the beginning of december
yeah i know that we're all we all have
short memories in the political sphere
but last i checked the calendar the
calendar goes august september october
november okay that means that like eight
weeks ago to 12 weeks ago that was the
fallout from afghanistan that was not
all that long ago and right now
afghanistan is about to face massive
starvation according to the new york
times one by one women poured into the
mud brick clinic the frames of famished
children peeking out beneath the folds
of their pale gray blue and pink burqas
many had walked for more than an hour
across this drab stretch of southern
afghanistan where parched earth meets a
washed out sky desperate for medicine to
pump life back into their children's
shrunken veins for months their once
daily meals had grown more sparse as
harvests failed wells ran dry credit for
flower from shopkeepers ran out now
reality was setting in their children
might not survive at the winter nearly
four months since the taliban seized
power afghanistan is on the brink of
mass starvation that aid groups say
threatens to kill a million children
this winter a million a toll that would
dwarf the total number of afghan
civilians estimated to have been killed
as a direct result of the war over the
past 20 years
this winter an
estimated 22.8 million people more than
half the population are expected to face
potentially life-threatening levels of
food insecurity according to the united
nations world food program and food and
agriculture organization of those 8.7
million people are nearing famine the
worst stage of a food crisis so you
could see millions of people died this
winter and that is thanks to the
greatness of joe biden but dana milbank
thinks that the media have been too mean
to joe biden
right this is the part that's truly
amazing so dana milbank has a piece
again over at the washington post
talking about how the media are worse to
joe biden than they were to donald trump
really really so i i feel like it's one
thing to run a bad headline about joe
biden who has caused an inflationary
spiral
he is going to be responsible for the
starvation of millions of people in
afghanistan he's responsible for russia
now threatening ukraine on its border he
is responsible for the chinese
government growing more and more
militant i mean he's responsible for a
lot of bad things is joe biden i feel
like there's a difference between
covering that stuff even remotely
accurately and spending four years
bloviating about how donald trump was
russian asset
and spending every single day of every
single year of the trump presidency
spinning around like tops based on
something dumb the guy tweeted
i feel like there's a slight difference
but according to dana milbank really
really joe biden should be treated with
kid gloves
he writes a sampling of headlines atop
the influential political playbook
newsletter over the past month
let the democratic freakout begin them
start to face the hard questions does
the white house owe larry summers an
apology the other big intra-democratic
fight no biff bump for biden white house
braces for a bad cbo score biden dithers
biden tries to call nerves about 20 24
the case for why biden is screwed
even the extraordinary news that jobless
claims had dropped to the lowest level
in 52 years came with a qualifier but
but but don't expect the numbers to
immediately change americans negative
perceptions of the economy
it isn't just politico says dana milbank
my impression of other outlets coverage
of president biden had been much the
same unrelentingly negative was it my
imagination
no it wasn't
artificial intelligence can now measure
the negativity with precision at my
request forge.ai a data analytics unit
of the information company fiscal note
combed through more than two hundred
thousand articles tens of millions of
words from 65 news websites to do a
sentiment analysis of coverage using
algorithms that give way to certain
adjectives based on their placements in
the story it rated the coverage biden
received in the first 11 months of 2021
and the coverage president donald trump
got in the first 11 months of 2020.
the findings painstakingly assembled by
fiscal note vice president bill
frischling confirmed my fear my
colleagues in the media are serving as
accessories to the murder of democracy
so you see if the media are mean to joe
biden because he's a crap president
they're serving as accessories to the
murder of democracy the murder of
democracy
according to dana milbank
the esteemed opinion journalist at the
washington post
after a honeymoon of slightly positive
coverage in the first three months of
the year biden's press for the past four
months has been as bad as and for a time
worse than the coverage trump received
for the same four months of 2020.
so um maybe it's because he surrendered
afghanistan
and we should be having a massive
economic surge right now and instead we
are having kind of a mild economic
crisis
and we missed our job marks about 300
000 jobs last month maybe it's inflation
has hit home maybe it's a supply chain
crisis maybe it's the fact that joe
biden said he was going to destroy the
the covet virus and instead we are
talking about nationwide lockdowns again
thanks to a variant by the way that we
now know to be more virulent and
probably less
fatal
than delta
but according to dana milbank you
shouldn't pay any attention to the
surrounding circumstances of the
presidency all you should pay attention
to is the d or the r so because donald
trump was r even if he was presiding
over a stronger economy than joe biden
even if donald trump was running in the
middle of a very contested election
none of that matters right the only
thing that matters is that trump should
have been treated worse by the media
says dana milbank think about that in
2020 trump presided over a worst
in-world pandemic response that caused
hundreds of thousands of unnecessary
deaths now by the way this is not
a a subjective take by dana milbank
right he says the media should have been
very very harsh on trump with regard to
his covet response because the world's
worst in-world pandemic responds that
caused hundreds of thousands of
unnecessary deaths um weird because it
seems like in this country we actually
develop the vaccines that everyone else
is taking on planet earth
right that was our cash that made that
happen
and by the way how's it going in the
rest of the world
i've noticed that um pretty much
everyone has gotten socked in the mouth
by covid
i
by the way if we are now going to credit
presidents with the number of deaths
thanks to kovid
joe biden has now presided over more
deaths from covid than donald trump did
during the entirety of 2020.
according to dana milbank donald trump
held a super spreader event at the white
house and got coveted 19 himself this by
the way is now the great sin if you get
coveted 19 yourself this means that you
are a sinner of some unforgivable sort
which is going to be really weird
because i would assume at some point
some people in the white house like say
jensahi would get kova does that mean
that she was some sort of evil character
dana milbang says he praised q anon
adherence embraced violent white
supremacists waged a racist campaign
against black lives matter demonstrators
remember according to
it's as though
you spit into a computer a thousand dana
millbank columns and a dana millbank
column popped out the other end the ai
actually came up with this column
trump got press coverage as favorable as
or better than biden is getting today
sure biden has had his troubles with the
delta variant afghanistan and inflation
but the economy is rebounding
impressively he assigned major
legislation he has restored some measure
of decency calm and respect for
democratic institutions has he cassie
though dana are you sensing a sense of
calm and decency from this white house
are you respecting how about respect for
democratic institutions you got the
white house ripping on the supreme court
every single day you have the democrats
in congress talking about killing the
filibuster you have the democrats
talking about completely rewriting the
bargain between the american citizen and
their government you're talking about
the federal government cramming down vax
mandates on 80 million employees across
the united
i feel like the restoration isn't going
all that well
but here's the point for the media it
doesn't matter what joe biden does joe
biden ought to be treated with kid
gloves because he is a democrat
and so according to dana milbank the
real threat here is the media are being
too kind to the authoritarians he says
we need a skeptical independent press
but how about being partisans for
democracy the country is in an
existential struggle between
self-governance and an authoritarian
alternative and we in the news media
collectively have given equal if not
slightly more favorable treatment to the
authoritarians
yes that's right i'm sure that the media
dana milbank have been very favorable to
the authoritarians like donald trump at
the expense of joe biden it's been very
rough for joe biden it's not that he's a
crowd president it is that the media
have been on the side of donald trump
and the authoritarians
in just one second we'll get to how the
media are actually treating the various
sides because let's be real about this
the media treat joe biden as a president
who is having his troubles but they
treat the other side of the aisle as
fish as as fascist racist this is how
they treat it right dana milbank's
perspective on the world is in fact
mirrored by broad swathes of the media
and you can tell this from their
coverage of these issues we'll get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about the need for life insurance if you
are a responsible adult you do need life
insurance i mean let's say that your
parents are actually king and queen of a
kingdom you have a couple of kids and
one of those kids happens to be gifted
with the ability to shoot ice from her
hands and you teach her to to try and
control this in certain ways but then
you decide to take a see an ill-advised
sea voyage and as your ship is being
washed under the waves you think to
yourself man number one i probably
should have gotten in touch with those
trolls a little bit sooner about a a
renewed second opinion and two i really
really need the life insurance that was
a bad move policy genius would have been
the help that you needed policy genius
makes getting a life insurance quote
very easy first head on over to policy
genius.com shapiro answer a few
questions about yourself in minutes you
can work out how much life insurance
coverage you need compare personalized
quotes to find your best price you could
save 50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius
their license experts will help you
understand your options and apply for a
policy the policy genius team works for
you not the insurance companies so you
can trust them to offer unbiased help
and advocate for you every step until
you are covered head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro right now get
free life insurance quotes see how much
you could save that is policygenius.com
shapiro again
policygenius.com
shapiro to get started okay so
according to dana melbank unbelievably
enough the media are kind to donald
trump but mean to joe biden
now this is the last vestige of people
who are desperate to save joe biden
considering that he's just a really
really bad president but it's going to
tie into the narrative that we're going
to see over the next couple of years
right the narrative that we're going to
see all the way up to 2024 because they
tried it in 2020 and it kind of sort of
worked just because donald trump is such
an outrageous character that the media
were able to pin on him pretty much
everything
donald trump committed one of the
cardinal sins of politics
the way that you win in politics is you
make it very difficult to vote for your
opponent you make it very easy to vote
for you donald trump makes it difficult
to vote for his opponent and very easy
for people to vote against him
he makes it hard for people to vote for
him right that's the story of 2020.
in 2016 he made it very difficult to
vote for hillary clinton he made it hard
to vote for him but people just hated
hillary more by 2020 by 2020 that math
had shifted a little bit he made it very
easy democrats and the media are now
going to try out the same playbook on
republicans so right now it's very
difficult to vote for democrats
democrats have done a horrible job
running the country
they're in control of the senate they're
in control of the house they're in
control of the presidency and we have
seen a stagnating economic response to
the pandemic we have seen calls for a
new lockdown we've seen complete foreign
policy collapse in afghanistan we're
seeing additional chaos in the
international scene which we'll get to
in a moment and so the media are left
with the same narrative that they tried
out in 2020
and this narrative of course is that
america is a white supremacist place and
republicans are representative of that
underlying white supremacism okay good
evidence of how media coverage actually
operates for example is the coverage of
a white nationalist march that happened
in washington dc by a group called
patriot front okay now i'd never heard
of this group because why would you hear
of this group
it's not a particularly large group it's
not a group of people who have a major
impact in the american public debate but
basically a bunch of white supremacists
decided to rally
in washington dc
and apparently this was worthy of
coverage
by places like the daily beast by places
like the washington right like like the
fact is you needed national coverage of
the of the white supremacist rally that
happened in front of the lincoln
memorial according to the daily beast a
group of white supremacists stormed
through downtown stormed
through downtown washington dc on
saturday evening bearing american flags
mildly menacing plastic shields while
marching to the beat of a snare drum
down the steps of the lincoln memorial
but after chanting aggressively about
their plans to reclaim america their
intended show of force stalled
spectacularly when they lost their ride
while the group had marched through the
city with threatening chants about their
plan to reclaim america by the end of
the night it was not even clear how they
intended to reclaim their u-haul the
rally by more than a hundred members of
the patriot wow 100 people
ah boy howdy they're probably gonna
overthrow the democracy those hundred
people held just blocks from the white
house sparked fear among many bystanders
immediately attracted the attention of
law enforcement who shadowed the group
to apparently prevent any clashes from
erupting
members wore uniform white gators
sunglasses blue jackets khaki pants
brown boots and hats some donned plastic
shin guards seeming to anticipate
violence
the patriot front leader thomas rousseau
spoke beside the capitol reflecting pool
bystanders booed asked about the reason
for the march resource that our
demonstrations are an exhibition of our
unified capability to organize to show
our strength not as brawlers or public
nuisances but as men capable of
illustrating a message and seeking an
america that more closely resembles the
interests of its true people
no arrests were made
and apparently the cops just kind of
stood around waiting for these people to
leave
two dozen members of the white
supremacist group could not leave they
were apparently stranded members of the
group had waited in a one-way roundabout
to depart in one of the u-hauls they
used to transport themselves but the
large rented moving van could not fit
them all so many of them were forced to
wait in 45 degree darkness as the bulky
orange vehicle made multiple trips over
the over the course of the nearly three
hours
patriot front used to be called vanguard
america okay so
why exactly is this relevant the reason
it's relevant is because this actually
received fairly widespread media
coverage
okay this this is a story that deserves
basically no media coverage because
here's the reality when 100 people rally
for anything that is not a big story
when you have when you have 100 people
rally for like i can get 100 people to
do pretty much anything in the united
states a country 330 million people kept
this received fairly widespread media
coverage and the question is why why
would white nationalists go viral on
twitter
like 100 of them
marching by the lincoln memorial
and the answer is because this ties into
a broader democratic narrative so when
you talk about dana milbank the coverage
of joe biden versus donald trump you
have to understand that it is not merely
the coverage directly of who the
president is that matters it is the
coverage of all the issues in the united
states that directly impact politics so
when you make it seem in the united
states for example that there is a grave
white supremacist threat which is
exactly the case that was being made by
many members of the media last year
when you make that case over and over
and over and meanwhile you suggest that
anyone who opposes black lives matter is
in fact a white supremacist the movement
in the group is in fact a white
supremacist they're not just opposed to
riots and looting they're white
supremacists if you if you believe that
then this makes you a bad person right
that sort of narrative drives how
politics is done in the united states
and you're seeing the media re-up this
right they're re-upping this in time for
2022. we'll get to that in just one
moment first let's talk about how you
protect yourself from another form of
crime that few people have heard of i'm
talking of course about home title fraud
the fbi calls title fraud one of the
fastest growing crimes it could ruin you
financially which is why you need home
title lock title fraud happens when a
criminal forges your signature on
documents stating you sold your home to
him
then he takes out loans against your
home and leaves you with the payment
you'll spend a fortune in legal fees
trying to prove you didn't commit fraud
home title lock puts a barrier around
your home's title the instant they
detect anyone from a cyber thief to a
renter to a relative trying to forge
their way onto your home title they help
shut it down cold which you need because
again insurance probably doesn't cover
this go to hometitlelock.com register
your address to see if you're already
victim and enter radio for 30 days of
free protection that is code radio at
home title lock.com criminals are always
devising new ways to get at your money
since your mortgage since your home is
probably your most valuable asset you
need home title lock you can go check it
out right now home title lock dot com
register that address see if you're
already a victim use code radio for 30
free days of protection that is code
radio at home title lock dot com all
right so
again the broader democratic narrative
which they tried out in 2020 and it
worked for them was the idea that
america was under true authoritarian
threat from the right and that was
exacerbated in the aftermath of the
november election by donald trump
talking loosely about the evils of the
election and suggesting the election had
been stolen from him and then it was
exacerbated more gravely by january 6
and the media claiming that we were just
moments from a coup attempt okay and now
the democratic through line is that if
you oppose black lives matter
in 2020 if you oppose the riots in the
looting if you thought it was a lie that
america's police are systemically racist
or more broadly that america was
systemically racist this means you are
part of the authoritarian white
nationalist movement that was the line
they used in 2020. then they moved that
through january 6 which they said was a
white nationalist uprising that was just
moments away from seizing the country
and now they're moving that into the
halls of congress so you have ilhan omar
trying to make the case that lauren
bobert and marjory taylor green are true
threat to the united states and so of
course is kevin mccarthy because they're
being mean to ilhan omar hey now here's
the thing about ilhan omar she's a
terrible human being ilhana omar is in
fact an advocate on behalf of terrorists
in the past she literally wrote a letter
to a judge that judge
was being asked to rule on the case of a
man from minnesota who's trying to join
isis she wrote a letter to the guy
saying that he was just a victim of the
american system and so the judge should
go easy
on him this is ilhan omar who voted
against iron dome funding for israel
which is a solely protective technology
that prevents hamas missiles from
hitting the interior of israel elena
omar
sympathizes with terrorist groups like
hamas
okay against israel
omar is a terrible member of congress
now none of this means that people
should be sending death threats to
anybody because this is a free civilized
country in which you should be able to
express your opinions without fear of
death threats death threats are illegal
or a reason okay but ilhan omar is now
saying that if she receives criticism or
if somebody makes an untoward joke about
her that this is just the threat to
american democracy writ large and
democrats are going to try and trot out
this playbook so while dana milbank
claims that the media are upholding
authoritarianism by me by being mean to
joe biden
the reason he means that is because many
members of the media think the same they
believe that the narrative in american
politics is that the democrats are the
good party and the republicans are the
white nationalist evil party and they're
going to do whatever they can to forward
that story
here is here is ilhan omar making this
case on state of the union
what is it like to hear that kind of
blatant bigotry
blatant islamophobia coming from a
fellow elected member of the house of
representatives
it's shocking and unacceptable
um and you know it's very unbecoming of
a congresswoman
to use that kind of derogatory dangerous
inciting language
against a colleague many of us thought
you know post 9 11 that we were on the
men's
many of us thought since you mean since
something happened to some people
that that 911
congresswoman omar
okay but again this is part of the
broader narrative now here's the thing
here's the thing when you watch those
white nationalists march on the steps of
the lincoln memorial and they're 100 of
them and they can't even get organized
enough to get a u-haul out of town does
that seem like a threat to the system to
you
did it really seem like we were on the
verge of being overthrown on january 6th
last year or did it seem like a bunch of
drugs and idiots decided to invade the
capitol building get themselves arrested
and then spend the next year in jail
because it seemed a lot more like the
latter to me that doesn't mean that
donald trump said good things between
the november election and january 6. he
did not i was highly critical of it you
can go listen to it
it does not mean that the people of
january 6 were not a threat to life and
limb to some police officers because
they did some physical damage to some
police officers they harm people and
they should go to jail for that
what it does mean is that if you're
looking at the systemic power in the
united states the systemic power in the
united states is behind the opinion of
people like dana milbank
and dana milbank is is
openly acknowledging what many in the
media believe which is their job to
protect democrats from the vicissitudes
of fortune it is their job to protect
democrats from the reality of their own
rule because if we expose the american
public to how bad they are at their jobs
the authoritarians might take over now
the reality is that the true
authoritarians in american life the ones
who have institutional power backing
them are the people who are talking
about shutting down your daily life
because of an omicron variant that by
the way is almost certainly less deadly
than delta
the people have control over your daily
life are the people who want more
control over your daily life
the supposed white nationalist
authoritarian threat to the united
states is not from the right
the racist threat to the united states
on a cultural level is from people who
advocate on behalf of a 1619 project
that pushes the notion that if you are
white in the united states you carry
some sort of race guilt
based on the color of your skin and that
if you're black in the united states
you're inherently a victim of the system
that is a message not echoed by a fringe
crazy few that is that is a message
echoed by nearly everyone in the
mainstream media
remember ilhan omar is sitting there on
state of the union having retained her
spot on the house foreign affairs
committee talking about why lauren
beaubert should lose her minority
committee assignment because lauren
bobert made an ill-advised joke about
ilhan omar carrying a bomb in her
backpack meanwhile illinois is an open
raging anti-semite and the democrats
have repeatedly led her off the hook for
it
and the media still have ilhan omar on
to talk about what a victim she is in
american society and how american
society is deeply racist
so which side actually has the institute
in order to actually effectuate a coup
you have to actually have the power you
have to have some institutional power to
back you you can't effectuate a coup
with a bunch of idiots from your local
drinking club
so effectuate a coup you have to have
some sort of institutional support the
institutional supports in the united
states are all on on behalf of a left
that mirrors the priorities of dana
milbank and he knows this which is why
he's attempting to shame everybody on
the on the media left into joining his
crusade not to honestly cover the biden
administration
and it's kind of fun to watch the media
try to spin their own bias in real time
so over the weekend chris cuomo formally
lost his job at cnn brian stelter who
until literally last week had been
saying that he thought that chris cuomo
might get his job back at cnn by january
he had to announce on air that chris
cuomo was gone
so here was uh brian stelter talking
about uh whether cnn had lost trust as a
result of the chris cuomo thing here's
the thing brian the answer is no you
never had trust because you guys are
just
an outlet for the democratic party
that's all
so there's such a you know a complicated
case here where yeah this apparently a
abc a former abc staffer someone who
worked with cuomo abc making this
allegation then you have all these
producers who currently work for cuomo
singing his praises and they are uh at
least the people i've talked to quite
disappointed that cuomo's been
terminated so a lot of tension in this
let's go david zerowick next ultimately
this is about trusted media as sarah was
referring to trusted media has cnn lost
trust as a result of this i know you
guys lost trust last year when you were
putting out headlines about how there
were fiery but mostly peaceful protests
happening in america's major cities now
you can try to make this about chris
cuomo and about how chris cuomo is is
very bad because he was helping his
brother uh when did it dawn on you that
chris cuomo was helping his brother was
it during the endless segments the
endless smothers brothers segments in
which you had him on with his brother
talking about how his brother was the
lovegov the greatest governor in america
as he shoveled elderly people with
coveted back into nursing homes killing
thousands of them and then covering it
up was that about the time when they
were stacking
elderly people in in corpse freezers
because of your brother was was that
about the time that that you guys think
you lost trust
or are we supposed to pretend that you
had trust until five seconds ago by the
way here was chris cuomo speaking out
about his firing over the weekend
he said
this is not how i want my time at cnn to
end i've already told you why and how i
helped my brother let me now say as
disappointing as this is i could not be
more proud of the team at cuomo
primetime and the work we did as cnn's
number one show in the most competitive
time slot i owe them all we'll miss that
group of special people who did really
important work that important work that
cnn was willing to protect up until
yesterday was work like lying about the
black lives matter riots like suggesting
that there was i remember chris cuomo
was saying on his show
what in the constitution says that riots
and looting are legal
and chris cuomo is a guy who who
with remarkable precision towed the
democratic party line which was fine
with the media it was only when he got
embarrassing that they had to shuffle
him off the moral coil
so when dana milbank makes the case that
the the media are somehow anti-biden no
the answer is that even the media cannot
hide how bad joe biden has been as
president but don't worry they'll come
back with the narrative next year just
in time for the democrats to compete for
congress
hey in the meantime the news just keeps
getting worse so remember joe biden
promised that he was going to end covet
remember that he wasn't going to shut
down the economy he's going to shut down
covet and then we had another jobs
report last month and that jobs report
showed a 210 000 jobs being added as
opposed to the 500 some thousand jobs
that were supposed to be added
meanwhile joe biden came out on uh on
friday to talk about the new economic
report which by the way is not very good
and he was croaking like kermit the frog
his voice completely changed it was like
george clooney had oddly taken over the
meat puppet that was joe biden here was
joe biden trying to explain that he just
had a cold it wasn't it wasn't coveted
guys it was just a cold
your voice sounds a little different are
you okay i'm okay i have a test every
day to see a coca test i have a
checkmate for all the strands what i
have is a one and a half year old
grandson who had a cold who likes to
kiss his pop
and he'd been kissing my anyway so uh
but it's just a cult so george clooney's
voice taking over the elderly body of
joe biden she had the cold over the
weekend this daughtering old fool
is the one who's presiding
over what should be a booming economy
and it's not over completely collapsing
foreign policy and meanwhile
we're supposed to believe that the
authoritarianism is coming from
a fringe part of the american political
spectrum that's the true fear according
to danny millen if you cover him
honestly you might be forwarding the
authoritarianism literally his white
house press secretary said over the
weekend that anyone who is not pro-vacs
mandate needs to get out of the way here
she was over the weekend
our message to governor kemp is uh if
you're not going to be a part of
protecting the people of georgia
ensuring that they can take steps to
save their own lives save their
neighbors lives and their children's
then you should get out of the way
because businesses are implementing
steps across the country including in
georgia to put in place vaccine or
testing requirements
hospital associations are universities
are
and people and what we've seen as one of
the biggest barriers and this is
something we can do from the federal
government is access
don't worry the authoritarianism is
coming from those 100 morons and racists
marching on the lincoln memorial steps
is not coming from the white house which
is literally telling governors whose job
it is to protect their citizens to get
out of the way so the federal government
can exercise authority it does not have
under the constitution of the united
states and by the way when i say they
have institutional support i mean across
the institutions
for here's a great example
you it is amazingly on the nose like the
writers of of this season
we're now in trump season
six so this writer this group of writers
they're too on the nose they really are
like
when you say that there's an
authoritarian threat and then people
literally start rewriting dictionary
definitions in order to meet what the
president of the united states wants
that's a pretty good example of
authoritarianism i'll explain that in
just one moment first let's talk about
the fact there are a lot of jobs to fill
not enough people to fill them we've got
like holiday lighting installers and
advanced snow makers i'm also
photographers if you need to hire for
one of those festive roles or any others
there's only one place you should go
ziprecruit.com dailywire after all if
zip recruiter can fill an advanced
snowmaker position they can most likely
help with your hiring needs how does it
recruiter do it well ziprecruiter uses
powerful technology to find and match
the right candidates up with your job
then it proactively presents these
candidates to you you can easily review
these recommended candidates invite your
top choices to apply for your job which
encourages them to apply faster no
wonder zip recruiter is the number one
rated hiring site in the united states
based on g2 ratings in fact zip
recruiters technology is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
on zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the very first day right now you
can try zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruit.com
dailywire discover hiring joy with zip
recruiter jingle your way on over to
ziprecruiter.com
we've been using zip recruiter over here
at dailywear for years you can do the
same ziprecruiter.com
dailywire go check them out right now
for those who haven't heard yet by the
way matt walsh has a new book it's
called johnny the walrus it soared to
the top of the amazon charts it also
became the number one book in amazon's
lgbtq plus category
there's a reason why it is one of the
most popular books in the country it's
hysterically funny and also the fact
that matt is now a children's author for
the lgbtq plus crowd is just
it's just delicious please head on over
to johnnythewalrus.com right now
pre-order your copy today also last week
joe biden announced his winter coved
plan its appearance his administration
is only going to double down on their
authoritarian policies not only did
biden announce he's extending the
federal mass mandate for public
transportation jensaki then admitted the
administration is actually considering
requiring that all americans be
vaccinated in order to fly domestically
despite all evidence demonstrating that
the vaccinated can still pass the
disease and also that airplanes are not
chief vectors of transmission so now if
you want to visit your family for the
holidays according to biden maybe you
need to drive across the country rather
than fly or comply the bite
administration is working overtime to
force you to do the latter this is why
our lawsuit against biden's vax mandate
for private employers remains vital we
need to stop this madness before it
grows if we prevail in federal court
we'll weaken the biden administration's
ability to implement these ridiculous
authoritarian measures
we need your help if you haven't signed
our petition and you need to stop what
you're doing right now head on over to
dailywire.com do not comply and add your
name we need to send an overwhelming
message to the administration the
american people will not comply
we have a goal of reaching a million
signatures that provide a major boost to
our legal challenge more than halfway to
the goal we need your help to cross that
finish line please sign the petition at
dailywire.com do not comply and then
share our petition with all of your
friends and family let's send a message
to the buy administration so loud they
cannot ignore us you are listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so when i talk about how
authoritarianism
is backed by chief
elements of the culture the dictionary
is a good example of this when they're
literally changing dictionary
definitions just to meet what joe biden
wants out of life you know where the
power lies in american life so for
example webster's dictionary literally
changed the definition of the ver of the
noun anti-vaxxer so it says the
anti-vaxxer a person who opposes
vaccination okay fair or laws that
mandate vaccination they literally
change the definition so they can call
people who are pro-vaccine but
anti-mandate anti-vaxxers
that's insane i'm not anti-vaccine
there's not a person on the right who's
advocated vaccines more loudly or more
continuously than i have been advocating
vaccines since before it was cool like
back to 2015
publicly and privately a lot longer than
that
and when it comes to covert vaccines i
told you when i got it i told you my
family got it like i'm very pro but i'm
not in favor of mandates because i still
believe that americans ought to have
freedom and the data evidence does not
back the idea that you are chiefly a
threat to others if you are unvaccinated
particularly to the vaccinated because
again the vaccinated are vaccinated and
the unvaccinated don't seem to care but
you have the dictionary literally
changing definitions in order to meet
the dictat of the biden administration i
mean that is that is orwellian as all
hell
and they keep doing this over and over
like in every element of american life
you remember
when there was an attempt to claim that
the use of the term sexual preference by
amy coney barrett during her judicial
hearings was some sort of of
rampant homophobia and the dictionary
literally changed the term preference
so that it would mirror maisie hirono's
idiocy on this the institutions of our
public discourse they march in absolute
lockstep
and then you wonder about where the
authoritarian threat is coming from by
the way speaking of the authoritarian
threat apparently
new york city under bill de blasio on
his way out he's announcing that there
will be a vax mandate for all private
sector employees starting on december
27th so they already have labor
shortages at the ers in new york city a
lot of public health
workers dropping out of the workforce
now he's announcing that all private
sector employees must be vast in new
york city starting december 27th
but but don't worry the real
authoritarian threat is white
supremacists are going to coup the
country or some some such garbage
by the way all of this is counter to the
science
because here's the reality we all know
that covet is going to become endemic
we uh it already is
not only that it turns out that the new
omicron variant is evading the vaccines
with regards to transmissibility it's
not evading it with regard to
hospitalization and death
but it is with regard to
transmissibility so is delta by the way
delta has already taken down the
transmissibility argument in favor of
mass vaccination because delta was
making it so that even the vaccinated
were passing covid to one another and to
the unvaccinated
here's where shelensky head of the cdc
acknowledging that covet is going to
become endemic but you still have our
covert authoritarians treating it as
though if we crack down hard enough it
won't be endemic anymore which of course
is unbelievably silly
we have seen now that this is likely to
become an endemic
disease here in the united states and
really around the world we have many
diseases that are endemic influenza
being one of them that cause us minor
challenges year after year and that we
can handle and tackle and that may very
well be what happens with covid
okay so um
and
and so it what if what if we're not
scared of that what if we now understand
that it's endemic and then people who
are facts are vast and people who are
unvexed are unboxed and that's it but
anthony fauci is now saying that people
like senator ron johnson from wisconsin
are fear-mongering because because ron
johnson said that anthony fauci was
fear-mongering he said that you keep
trying to scare the living hell out of
people and the reality is that people
are just not all that worried anymore
because they've all had the opportunity
to get vast and that's all you can
pretty much do here's anthony fauci
complaining though
oh he did the exact same thing with aids
he he over hyped it he created all kinds
of fear saying it could affect the
entire population when it couldn't and
he's doing he's using the exact same
play playbook for kobe over hyping covid
it's already killed 780 000
americans and over 5 million people
worldwide so i don't have any clue of
what he's talking about okay what he is
talking about fauci knows exactly what
he's talking about when johnson says
you're over hyping covet what he means
is the risk factors for young healthy
americans are extremely low for covet
for children they're almost non-existent
yes you're over hyping covet because
again you refuse to mention the age and
health striations with regard to
response to the virus we all know this
and you're over hyping omicron right you
have anthony fauci out there on the tvs
every day explaining how omicron might
kill us all so we have to be ready for
full lockdowns and maybe we ought to
have travel bans and all the rest of
this
here is the latest from the jerusalem
post
quote
new data published on saturday suggests
oh mikron is more contagious but not as
dangerous as other variants according to
professor drawer
a senior physician from hadassah hebrew
university medical center he said we
have to say this with a lot of caution
but if we look at the currently
available information there's reason to
believe the variance is spreading fast
but maybe it is not so dangerous
according to south africa's chawain
district to omicron variant patient
profile which is the epicenter of the
omicron outbreak 80 percent of hospital
admissions in the previous two weeks
were people below age 50 the vast
majority of whom did not require oxygen
support
okay by the way who was saying last week
when all this omicron talks started that
it was a bunch of hype that omicron was
more because this is what viruses
typically do they become more
transmissible and they and and more
virulent and less deadly
right who because again viruses don't
typically want to kill all the hoes if
they kill all the hosts and the virus
goes away so instead they like to
circulate in the population and as
variants occur they get less and less
deadly but more and more transmissible
okay so
the replacement of delta with
omicron might actually not be the worst
thing in the world because i have to
choose between a virus that eventually
everyone will get like delta which is
slightly more deadly and one that
everyone will get like omicron that is
slightly less deadly i'll take omicron
but we were all supposed to panic about
this remember it was very important to
panic about this
and not only was it super important to
panic about all of this we were supposed
to talk about how stronger measures were
going to help our economy that's
something more on ron clayne the chief
of staff over at the white house
literally tweeted he said that stronger
coveted measures have made the economy
stronger which is patently untrue which
is why bill de blasio is now talking
about force vaccinating every private
employee in new york city
okay this is crazy but don't worry the
true authoritarian threat is going to be
the people who are who are white
supremacists and marching
by the by the dozens
in washington dc that's really where we
should be fearful and by the way the
only way that we can apparently win over
oh macron and the rest is not only
authoritarian mandates but more spending
so congress is seeking to ram through
more and more and more spending
according to the wall street journal
congress is racing against the clock to
complete a series of must-pass pieces of
legislation with democrats also pushing
to finish their roughly 2 trillion
social and climate policy legislation by
the end of the year
congress is expected to focus this week
on a defense policy bill known as the
national defense authorization act or
ndaa which was held up in the senate
last week over provisions regarding
russia and china instead of the senate
passing its own bill a compromise bill
is expected to come to the house for a
vote meanwhile lawmakers have to raise
the debt limit by around mid-month when
the treasury has set emergency measures
to pay government obligations will run
out but that's not stopping them from
talking about that two trillion dollars
build back better nonsense
okay so
you wonder why the coverage of the buy
administration may be bad
maybe it's because they're really really
bad at their jobs maybe because they're
really bad at their jobs they try to
spend it away but they're really bad at
their jobs here's labor secretary marty
walsh trying to explain that the economy
is really picking up steam when
everybody can see that it's kind of
flaming out here
we have to look at this as a whole plan
since president biden has taken office
the economy is getting stronger and
stronger and stronger every day uh we're
seeing nearly six million people return
to the workforce we've seen a full two
points drop off the unemployment number
uh we're seeing opportunities that
people haven't had
for forever quite honestly no one
believes this by the way that new york
city new move they're strengthening back
screening and indoor public
establishment okay now you have to be
vast if you are five years old and going
to a movie
not kidding this is going to mark levine
who's the public health commissioner of
new york city it's now going to include
as of december 14th all five to 11 year
olds and it will require a second shot
so
yeah
maybe it's this maybe the american
people just don't like this crap maybe
they just don't like it alrighty we will
be back here later today with an
additional hour of content coming up
soon the mount wall show airs at 1 30 pm
eastern be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica crans the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show